c'est madonna bissonnet la dérive est
chez elle dans son salon à plusieurs
millions
eh bien oui nous y voici encore je suis
tellement désolé et attristé
d'être obligé de repousser les
spectacles une fois de plus est cette
fois ci c'est ma santé qui m'oblige à
reporter les spectacles de la tournée
européenne et malheureusement d'en
annuler certains autres mes médecins me
suivait je reçois des traitements mais
j'ai toujours des spasmes musculaires la
récupération prend beaucoup plus de
temps que je pensais mais je me dois
d'être en pleine forme en pleine santé
pour que je puisse donner 100% de
moi-même sur la scène car c'est ce que
vous méritez pour qu'on n'y croit jamais
on y croit jamais on est toujours là
présent mais il a
décalé pour 2023 2024 pas très bon signe
là où je te rejoins laurent c'est que
que ce soit même la mort de son mari au
thon souviens je vous raconte cannes ou
la mort de son mari lorsqu'il était à
l'église qui sort de l'église donc tout
était mise en scène y avait des caméras
il y avait des petits stickers au sol
pour le coq qu'elle s'arrête à un
endroit très précis pour les caméras et
tout ça tout est mis en scène on aime ou
on n'aime pas mais c'est tout échoue en
permanence et même côté le final on se
rejoint laurent s'est fait manière
showtime à l'américain
avec d'autres pas je le raconte
rapidement je vais à vegas et je vais la
voir chanter alors elle chante en
anglais qu en anglais qu en anglais et
tout d'un coup elle chante une chanson
en français ne me quitte pas il dit
maintenant je vais vous chanter un me
quitte pas de jacques brel c'est une
chanson qui me touche tellement
tellement tellement que je suis pas si
je pourrais aller au bout quand lille
etc si je peux pas je suis vraiment
désolé mais j'aurais tenté
ce qui t'a pas ne me quitte pas et
alors au bout d'une minute trente
précisé le fait ne me quitte pas à eva
est sûre tourner elle pleure lumière
noire elle s'arrête elle revient le dit
pardon j'ai pas pu aller au bout bon
très bien c'est très touchant deux jours
après manque de bol je suis invité par
valérie michelin qui étaient là bas et
qui me dit vient la voir et je salue
toujours je meurs fait le show et tout
d'un coup et maintenant je vais tenter
de chantier ne me quitte pas j'espère
vraiment que je vais aller au bout parce
que c'est une chanson qui est vraiment
touchés un touché en touchant pour moi
fait que je me demandais si elle me fait
ne me quitte pas il ya une trente deux
piles ne me quitte pas hélas hélas
[Applaudissements]
et là tu te dit
tout c'est fake
et la maison de justin bieber maisons
coloniales date et datant des années 30
il l'a payé 8 million et demi c'est
celle-là de dollars bof mais ma jolie
mais perd jolie parlons harnais konon
une blague elle est magnifique alors
maintenant madonna la maison de madonna
we madonna telle collection céline dion
alors là on ne doit pas être la
vulgarité
et voilà les travaux qu'elle a fait
l'effet 15 millions de dollars de
travaux pour qu'ils aient cette espèce
de deux toboggans immonde pour sedan
aquatique oui on aime beaucoup mais pas
beaucoup de goût d'acheter à bas
dicaprio voilà il s'est offert une villa
estimée à 7 millions de dollars
non c'est dans le quartier de los feliz
a los angeles c'est joli oui mais il est
du coup ce garçon efféminé ses plus
petits lacets menant à
acculer mois
ah bah voilà plus de 1000 m abbas et la
colère
ça ressemble voilà
là ils ont vécu là avec vanessa paradis
elle est bien à vendre pour 23 millions
de dollars en 2016 mais ils ont toujours
pas réussi à se débarrasser s'y
intéresse quelqu'un la dernière je vais
vous dire la dernière à votre avis à qui
appartient elle regarde
une salle de bain c'est difficile ils
habitent donc ces cas quand pas prêt ce
cas vous avez eu toutes ces photos c'est
magnifique
alors c'est un peu rococo cerrato kitsch
pas terrible ça allait faire l'amour non
alors dire sans cesse en normandie les
besoins de leur
domaine et des
photos sur internet
qu'on a violé
les pneus spears est enceinte alléluia
est basée là oui bah c'est super
attendait rappelons rappeler si tu
recommences est choquante a été sous
tutelle son utérus ne lui appartenait
pas oui elle a repris possession de ses
ovaires non mais moi je suis très
distant mais qu'elle en fasse autre
chose deborah elle n'est pas bien ce
qu'elles en fassent les bons jours de
développement pour noël la caisse et des
ovaires alors regardons mais c'est une
bonne nouvelle mais pour qui enfin c'est
dans un enfant elle n'est pas apte à
s'en occuper quand tu es maman et que tu
es instable émotionnellement une
grossesse est chamboule tas après un tat
tous les flics le baby blues est tout
sauf que ce qui est drôle c'est que
depuis cette annonce la star a dit
qu'elle préférait faire une pause sur
les réseaux sociaux jeux mais dès le
lendemain à l'art posté une vidéo en
montrant en fait comment cet enfant
avait été fait
[Musique]
la seule chose qui pourrait dérangeantes
c'est qu'on sait qu'elle est sous
traitement donc ça ça pourrait être
dérangeant par rapport à sa grosse tête
je suis d'accord mais ça je pourrais moi
aussi de faire valoir ses mains de
nabila dérivés études chez elle dans son
salon à plusieurs millions
enfin